[Music]
[Music]
okay why don't we why don't we go ahead
and get started thank you all for coming
there's a number of you I don't know my
name's bill Hirsch I'm chair of the
department and overall director of the
program although dr. McQueen II directs
the bioinformatics and computational
biology tract so we're here today for
the dissertation defense always an
exciting time for a student who's
completing their studies hopefully
completing their studies I I have good
confidence in Issa so Issa my my re is
has been a student in our program I
assume most of you in the room know him
he originally obtained bachelor's
degrees in biology and chemistry from
Portland State obtained a master's
degree in biochemistry molecular biology
here at OHSU and then he joined our
program prior to joining our department
he worked on a large project elucidating
the vaccine induced correlated
protection against a highly pathogenic
HIV oma log in the rhesus macaque model
i think i pronounced all that correctly
for his dissertation he's focused on
developing a computational framework for
robust identification of rare cellular
subsets and single cell technologies so
he's defending his dissertation just for
those of you who are not familiar with
our department the way these work is
that first the candidate presents his
talk usually 30 to 45 minutes and then
he takes questions from everyone at that
point the public the audience except for
his committee is excused and then
there's additional question questioning
from his committee and then he's excused
and then the committee makes the
determination so I won't take up any
more of Isis's time and
thank you everyone for coming it's such
a exciting time to be presenting my work
to you in my research and although this
is going to be a part of the results and
the work that I did it's the focused on
one platform of Technology so sorry so
in general we were interested in finding
computational models to be able to
identify rare Sleater subsets from
heterogeneous virginius mix of self and
that's because rare soyou're subsets are
important clinically and for research
determinants of health and disease for
example one leukemic cell in 10,000
healthy self is prognostic of minimal
residual residual disease in adoptive
lymphoblastic leukemia and on the other
side of interest more recent research
interest is the circulating tumor cells
where publications are saying that are
showing that there are around one in 10
million healthy cells so they're very
important in terms of determinants of
health and disease what makes them so
difficult to identify is two factors I'm
showing this in a bimodal situation one
is effect size and which is a
standardized unit of difference between
two populations and the smaller that
difference the more difficult it is to
define a discriminatory boundary between
them and to be able to classify them as
one or the other on the other side
marginal frequency defines how many of
those are present relative to the other
population and the less there are of
those positive paths it's harder to make
a determinant a judgment call on where
the drug boundary line as well as it's
not enough events for training machine
learning or computational methods
usually so that's where the difficulty
comes in furthermore in real-world
applications
if there is it's not usually a binary
classification that we're interested in
each population may be associated with
false or negative positive negative
positive race sorry I said there are
false positive or in false negative
rates there's also this idea of high
dimensionality where a lot of times we
have to do this feature selection to be
able to do the classification that we
need phenotype scan are not necessarily
also distinct they could be gradients
and that also makes them difficult and
more importantly there are confounding
factors in experiments and everything
that is done that affect the
classification especially rarely about
this as I said confounders but are
impede computational methods but it's at
multiple scopes so you have to think
about standardizing protocols and
experimental and analytical methods so
that we can improve the classification
or goal that we have in the scope of
this research for example multiplexing
is one way to be able to do that but
another way to overcome such limitations
that confounding factors produce is a
map is normalization and here's a very
big commonly used method that I'm trying
to just introduce the idea of
normalization with in there are two
datasets single-cell are six data sets
here labeled a and B and you can see on
the log scale gene counts the two have
are different and these are ten genes
that I've just chosen to show that
although these two datasets are similar
in terms of what they're trying to
represent they are shifted that are
there under a quantitative measurements
differ from each other and what
quantitative normalization is trying to
do is create make the distributions of
the two days that's similar so that we
can run models that have assumptions
about them having identical
distributions and effects are like that
so
the and and and what memorization we
choose actually depends on a lot of
times the the experimental design and as
well as the protocol or the instrument
that we're using the instrument that
were using for that I have worked on
focus mostly on my this in my
dissertation is single sorry and I see
there are different instruments that do
this they all start with sync capturing
of single cells for each cell the mRNA
is quantified captured converted to cDNA
amplified and then sequence with a
specific platform once the raw reads
have been acquired that we need to do a
lot of bioinformatics and Advan these
specifically defined pipelines to make
sure it's the quality control it
remove any aberrant cells or unwanted
debris and in the end we have these
single specific normalizations that are
done depending on the platform again to
normalize for RNA content library size
and the variation that's between the
cells usually caused by unwanted
biological variation but this process
could be biased against are rare
cellular subsets and a lot of times the
focus of these pipelines is not rare so
your subsets and so it may look aberrant
but they are removed because they don't
for that hypothesis that was already
used it's not in the focus and as I said
earlier are the whole motivation of this
my dissertation has been to find a
computational method to be able to
classify rare serious subsets and a
parallel to what normal human experts do
as well where they go read literature
and find examples of the phenotype or
the signature that they're interested in
I have modeled I've also made the same
assumptions where there is always some
sort of a training that we can do on
foot from data to be trained on to then
be able to infer on new data sets and
the the training the the Japan that that
assumption focuses us on a set of dump
machine learning methods called
supervised methods where there is this
training data set that the algorithm
trains on and develops a classification
model and a new test that is used to
predict a new classification but in the
real world if the marginal frequency
between the test set and the training
set of the population of interest
differs significantly supervised methods
many of them have issues also supervised
methods assume that the the training
data and the tests that are come from
the same source which means that they
intrinsic distributions should have this
idea of identically distributed which in
most apply faces is not and that's why I
showed the normalization of potential
you can resolve that but that's a big
hammer in that toolbox so transfer
learning is another domain of machine
learning that we can that can also be
able applied here specifically that
what's common one of the settings of
transfer learning is called transductive
transfer learning where we do some
learning and we make some inference the
major difference is that in super
transfer learning we're generalizing the
training and adapting it to the tester
whereas in supervised methods that's not
the case furthermore transfer learning
does not have an identically distributed
assumption also it is also in theory not
sensitive to the difference between
marginal frequency between the two
training and testing visit so in overall
that's the better domain of machine
learning to vo to research so let's look
at an example of transductive chance for
learning let's have some you have some
training data which you can imagine this
is rows of cells and columns of features
if there are flow cytometry RNA seek and
and that dataset can be either split or
sampled to make multiple
upsets because they're non-identical if
you train on each one independently you
get a slightly different classification
hyperplane so from each one we train the
machine learning algorithm specifically
a linear SVM to derive at a
classification per each sample because
they are slightly different we can get a
a mean of the classification hyperfine
derive from all of these samples as the
mean or ensemble hyperplane now we have
three test data that we get to want to
classify with that mean hyperplane but
because of confounding factors that I
talked about earlier the data search
could be confounded and so the outcome
is not what if you did now imagine I
said the in a bimodal situation where
there are two binary classification
setting we expect to have two peaks in
the middle of a lower density region so
that we're pacified
doesn't matter how many input features
we have right it could be twenty
twenty-five whatever but when it gets
multiplied into the hyperplane you're
actually because it's a binary
classification you expect to get two
peeps and a center in the key but
confounding factors can affect the
effect size between the two populations
or cause a shift in that two to cause a
problem in plasma classification so two
possible ways that we can adapt this
specific generalized or mean hyperplane
to these data sets is the way to go on
two ways to do that is either by by a
shift or rotate so bias shift is again
this is on the y axis which is again
doesn't matter what how many features
are inputted but once it gets multiplied
into the hyperplane you are getting that
on the y axis right so the y equals that
not forget on that function so on the y
the predicted outcome depending on which
where the bias is the the outcome the
mapping can be shifted as
here or if it's the wrong rotation it in
effect the effect size between the two
populations so the idea is to find the
right rotation and bias to make as a
form of adaptation to the test set so
you're using the test set that you're at
hand to make these two to these changes
and that is actually the contribution of
lead-out in 2011 as part of their
pipeline it's an overview of it they're
a bunch of individual algorithms in the
first few I'll get a little bit more in
detail but the whole point is that this
training in the beginning is then
adapted to make the final inference so a
little bit more detail until II allow
our pipeline so they propose their work
on flow cytometry data which in general
there's multiple samples each sample has
multiple cells in it or thousands of
cells in it and many conditions many
situations so generally they each one
can be represented as an individual
sample each for site for example but in
RNA seek we usually have one large data
set that has a few thousand or a few
hundred cells so we don't have multiple
samples of that so the difference which
I'll get to later a little bit more when
I'm talking about single taralacey
is that major difference that in Forli
at all they derived directly each of
these is one sample and they derive a
linear classified hyperplane from that
sample then because each condition each
experiment from those four cytometry
could be very different because of
issues or problems or real biology they
they're either robust mean which is less
bias towards those big outliers
so once the training is complete the the
next module or the next algorithm in the
pipeline what is trying to do is correct
for a major shift in in the compared to
the test data compared to all other
training so what it's doing is it
compares the location or the
position of where the testator's been
mapped to a median of where the
trainings were mapped so you can do a
general shift near the training so it
corrects as a first step to that
adaptation process then once the shift
is done the algorithm defines several
potential biases as candidates so we can
see where which one's the best one and
it counts how many cells fall within the
margin near that boundary but not near
that each one of those biases but as you
can imagine the depending on how far
these biases are defined and how big
this margin is the the line that is
producing them it could be very rigidly
and produce multiple local minima even
if you smooth it with a Gaussian
smoother you might get multiple local
minima and when you try to look for that
that expectation where is like that
low-density minimum between those two
peaks where you want to cut the data you
might have a second option with it's
biasing that gradient descent algorithm
and very descent is the algorithm that
actually does that for these dips to
find the potential minimus to call us
the correct pipes and so a the next part
of the next module of the algorithm in
the lead aisle is finding the correct
rotation and that's done similarly to
define a bunch of possible rotations you
do count of relative to those rotations
how many cells fall within a certain
margin and that defines this kind of a
curve that also has multiple local
minima but what you're looking for is to
define it as the lower position in that
the look at the optimal minimum again it
can be the the gradient descent can be
biased by any of these even if it's
smooth which is in this case that I'm
showing the smooth but the leann our
algorithm is not available upon request
the data set we show it is not available
so how can I test single sarcastic data
how can I evaluate a rare state of
substance with it so the first
was to implement a baseline version
based on what they published as
algorithms in their manuscript and
obviously then that becomes a little
different because it's I the way I coded
it in in another language with their the
algorithms that are kind of supporting
it that are from the language that are
used causes slight variation so it's not
an exact one-to-one but it's intended
for open source release and so any
researcher anyone kept in the future be
able to expand upon it and I'm also
using so our first aim was to implement
adapt and validate this previously
theorized transfer learning framework to
classify these cellular subsets of
signatures especially realistic subsets
in neo single science dictator once I
had some similar this built I had some
pilot data I had some data from the
loons in their lab that I tested with
and I came up with some list of
potential extensions that I could make
to make the algorithm better especially
to be able to generalize across datasets
and especially to get to focus on rare
cider substance so a view overview of
what it looks like so if you design a
similar I kept the same structure of the
the proposed algorithm so between the
baseline and the extension the first
three are the same so we did the
training is the same the general shift
is the same but in the extended version
how we define the look where the biases
and where the proper rotation is changed
as well as a new function Jin the how
the smoothing is that is also chancres
the the the way they propose the
smoothing made it in producing a lot of
local minima and I wanted a more of a
smooth curve so I even used a different
way to estimate the better bandwidth to
smooth the and a little bit more in
detail into each one of this but on top
of all of this the similar structure I
had a new additional module that
actually is for
specifically for rare cellular subsets
and I'll get a little bit more into what
that does is well in a sec so the first
extension for the algorithm part four
which is trying to find that bias as I
said the whole idea is to be able to
find a smooth line so instead of finding
multiple biases and a margin around them
to scan through the count and just I
just did a direct density but that needs
to be smooth with that new bandwidth
method to give you that gives additional
smoothness to the curve from that to
derive multiple other additional
evidences of topology the first
derivative and the inverse of the second
derivative are computed of this density
curve which also have relationships to
how the the rates of increase decrease
and all this you can imagine if you
remember calculation with first and
second they ever do is you're affecting
the the rate of change in this curve
that were the first derivative and the
second derivative is the invert is the
derivative of the step of the first
derivative and then in verses is the
multiples over there recall in the
denominator you put its one over there f
of X there so in the count getting tired
of talking
so - and I should just say that that
doing this directly without defining any
of those biases and the margins around
them removes a whole margin parameter
that's in the fur in that in the
baseline as a bias because what you have
to do is find usually the correct margin
and if you go by a default setting you
may not have the correct margin so
that's that's actually a benefit of that
and the the last part this on the
finding the rotation is a similar thing
we want to try and make it more smooth
but the counts are now different this is
no longer it's counting its relative to
the amount of false negatives that are
in the function and you're trying to
minimize the number of negative calls
that is making and that innately is a
smoother function and then with that
update on the bandwidth selection also
makes it a little even more smooth to be
able to find the optimal minima as
opposed to a local minima so that new
module that I talked about about focuses
on the real failure subsets it works for
both baseline and the extended versions
of the algorithm of the whole pipeline
but basically the whole idea is when
you're trying to make an inference on a
rare subset that the prediction is
difficult to make because there's a
potentially a large number of local
optimal local minima that you have to
choose from and the the whole idea is to
from the training to get an estimate of
potentially where that populations
frequency is plus some error because we
truly don't know the margin of frequency
of the in the test that and that can be
used to reduce the narrow the search
space in in the in the mapping so that
now we find that local minimum their
optimal minimum so once that I had
they're both the baseline and the
extended versions built and tested the
idea was we need to evaluate and
benchmark that its performance to some
other previously work done there in part
in the next part of the
we won't quantify classification
generalizability which is how well does
it perform when it goes from learn from
one dataset and in first on another
dataset source differently and finally
in Part C where we were interested in
evaluating how well it does on the
performance on their cellular subsets
the data sets that we used I acquired
them online from a publication that has
already tested six other classifiers the
top performing classifiers and E and so
I can use parallel to the work and
whatever my results are I can compare
directly to them so there are two data
sets one is the one shown here and you
can see that March not only the margin
of frequency of the three labels because
what we're trying to do here is classify
the cell cycle labels and what is known
about the both data sets so the margin
of frequency of the labels that are
interest which is sg-1 or g2m which is
different across the two and more
importantly they're its source from
different protocols this one's a fluid
time c1 and this one's from quartz seek
so innately these two are highly
confounded and different by the
protocols and methods used to parallel
I'll work with the work that was done by
the published work with the other
classifiers those folks the style don't
at al they found four hundred and five
cell cycle genes from a creation of a
bunch of other latest beta bases and so
forth and and their testing and finding
the right appropriate feature selection
on these two data sets from those four
hundred five cells they showed their top
performance with a very good signature
using 40 of those genes but before they
did that they present their work with
some sort of a with a normalization
technique which they use rank based
normalization so again these the these
two are not identically distributed as I
said it's one of the hallmarks of
transfer learning and the margent
frequencies are different in with you so
let's visualize how these datasets look
just holistically
in terms of the principal component
analysis so here's the innocent one a
and B is this one colored in green and
using the 405 genes or the 40 genes we
can see that the signature does reduce
the distance between them the 40 gene
signature but if there's two separate
and they also show a general trend that
they both have that that the g1 cell the
green ones are this way in between of
each one is the g2 themselves and then
the SL S phase but like I said the style
don't allow they rank normalization so
if I'm doing a benchmarking at first
that's the what I need to focus on as
well but which is I'm showing this in
the center here so rank normalization
causes the two data sets to no longer
have that distance between they don't
have that shift between them and but
still still retains that general trend
of the data is in the first and second
principal component component on the
other side there's another shot
like I mentioned contour normalization
is another technique commonly used and
that produces a similar but a little
slightly different distribution of there
and at a non rank based method
normalization I used the log median
absolute value normalization which has a
very
squishing effect so as I said earlier
supervised methods can be biased by and
supervised and unsupervised method which
is completely done to be able to so I
just start again here I'm showing an
unsupervised clustering which is a
method used to go to find subtypes into
this in the data set and what I'm
showing on top is the actual classes
nomen labels where the red is g1 the
blue is s and green is g g 2m
that the normalizations effect the soup
unsupervised clustering that is done on
on these cells and produces different
clusters although it's not immediately
possible you can see is that the
groupings change big based on the
normalization they used and supervised
methods which I'll show as well are also
biased by this as well by the
normalization technique and additionally
the 40 gene signature that they found is
not an optimal signature for a linear
classifier which is what I am going to
be using as part of the framework that I
developed so I I first find a potential
set of gene sets that would be an
alternative to that 40g set so what I
did was for each class label up from
this 505 so psycho genes I ranked them
by feature importance to the foot to the
label and using from that set using the
top three four five of the very top 50
which is shown here and repeating this
multiple times during conducting 10-fold
cross-validation and computing this sum
square error of classification here so
you can see the error is high there is
only three genes and it drops down when
it's coming to them like around here 16
17 or so and the optimal number of genes
that would be used I'll show you later
that I'm using as opposed to that 40
genes of the paper is the minimum
finding the minimum of these use of
these measurements error measurement so
here's what so that in a way is a
supervised method right so this this
linear SVM that I'm using to be able to
do this is a supervised method and you
can see that in supervised methods is
also biased by that the normalization a
quant norm rank waves nor warlord math
contour to the large scaled counts which
is the first one and you can see that
just look at holistically the change in
the type of the number of genes that
could come in and how they if germ asta
Kalia fected affects these changes
because it's really difficult to be able
to show that there are actually
different genes found by each of these
proofs that I took here's the style down
at our for the genes down here and the
yellow is showing the g2 s
the pink is you want and the blue is the
and Locke still counts rank normalized
normalize and loved math normalized and
for each one and so you can see that in
fact the the gene sets that I found to
be able to be best classify them with a
linear classifier is different than the
originals for your genes the limitation
here could be that they over fit to the
training which means they're using these
gene sets we could over flip to the
training set and not be able to
generalize them to train set which is
what I will show you that it not the
case so an overview of the what the
classification is happening
like I said we're classifying these cell
cycle labels in these two data sets
first we reduce them to the 405 cycle
genes as I said normalization is done we
can just do it at this stage then reduce
it by either that forty gene set or that
top-end gene said that I just described
depending on which one that we use and
so now we have these narrow gene
expression matrices which way I can
create training and validation sets from
and in a 5-4 cross-validation
where four faults is help and inference
is done on this one and it's rotated so
that every every fold is helped once
back and training is on first four and
then the other and for external
validation we'll be testing the
generalizability of the classifier is we
classified on four or four folds from
the one dataset and they're influencing
on the other one so to make the final
call of the classifiers we have to
because there's some stochasticity
associated with the classification in
integrated descent algorithm that tries
to find the local minima and a few other
features in the actual framework what
running at one time will not produce a
good result we have to run it multiple
times and get it I think it's better to
do it that way and to get a probability
associated with each class level and
then make the final call on that and and
that's done in this sort of like I said
the K fold work the validation is held
and then there's training is done on the
rest and that's rotated across and this
whole thing is repeated in this case
twenty-five times
now to to compare models I'm going to
quickly introduce the f1 measure which
is a harmonic mean between precision and
recall it's a good measure because in
rare cellular subsets we are worried
about what measure to use if for example
accuracy would be bad you can classify
something as 99% accurate but reality is
you didn't you may not have done a good
job
if the rare substance is like 1% itself
so but nf1 is actually a good measure
that kind of balances if it's a
combination measure circuit balances
these two and it's fairly well used in
literature as well for this sort of
purposes so as I said the first part in
part two was to build it up I'll attempt
benchmarked performance so here is and
this figure on the side is what's I
don't know is it from directly from
their manuscript and what I like to show
is actually the more important like the
thing to look at here is their red lines
which is the macro average f1 scores
across and so in that regard but in
reality you have to compare each cell
cycle label to each cell cycles or in
making comparisons but as a whole if you
make an average column which perform
better let's look at just the red lines
and we can see that on average the
income with the rank normalized rank
normalization we didn't perform style
don't allow and but if we look at did we
up perform a linear basic SVM yes we did
with the both of them but with the big
sign a little better now what about the
other normalization that I talked about
so compared to again to each other now
over to that linear scan we can see that
the log map actually produced the
highest of all of them and even if you
want to
a different type of no-decision the corn
or it produces higher normalization than
the rank norm with the RTO free work so
again there is some effects from the
yard the normalization on the
classification right so the log map also
needs any of them but I don't get to
attack there's a reason that that's
actually not the right thing but I just
want to highlight that if this log map
was in here the next highest one which
is very coudn't to one of the higher
points here just maybe a slightly out of
this one which it but their method the
actual method that they talk about is
this pair's method so these these are
not their met the rest is not their
develop method they develop this Paris
method but regardless the under just
large-scale counts without any
normalization we produce a pretty well
classification f1 sperm if that lokmat
wasn't there but lock might be come on
now with the top engine so because like
I said the 40 gene signature is good but
not optimized for a linear classifier so
these top and jeans are are we good and
we can see that through throughout they
all produce higher and much higher than
those scores so again like I said the
the mutation is how well does this
transfer because this internal
validation that we're doing is just on
one data set then split apart and one
part is being held out for that testing
and then rotated so part twos about
generalizability where you're learning
on one dataset you're inferring on the
other and again start with the basic one
where we're looking at
direct comparison we don't be there
score the highest one the fact they are
cheap was with their feet with the PC a
method that meets their own method but
and there are reasons a little bit for
that
but regardless time if you just compare
to a linear yeah
but doing it transfer learning as
opposed to supervised method which are
the SVM as a family Nemeth then compared
to the other love normal now look at the
log map it didn't generalize so that's
why I hope your excitement that but if
you ignore this guy you can see that the
next highest scores are either on the
log counts or potentially the quantum
lon
but in general this one produces is one
of the next highest one as well so come
now the well that's I was just saying
that here that still PCA is beats that
but the the the top and jeans now the
generalization is not perfect but you
can see that something the trend with
the log math still remains but you can
see that I some of these are producing
higher classification even generalized
click onto this other new dataset so if
the top and did not over fit to training
those signatures so regardless of that
you can see that the what's the highest
achieved f1 score by these methods is on
the log counts followed by the corn or
with the extended version so the now to
the actual point which is the
registration subset to be able to
evaluate those now on all honesty as I
showed that these cells were not rare by
any definition and in my manuscript in
my dissertation I kind of defining in
less than 5% but based on other work
the here we are not that in director so
how do we get that and that I did in
silico resampling there's several
different methods that you can do the
simplest one is up sampling the negative
class basically you put you bring in all
the positive class that you want for
example in this case the g2m cells and
you just randomly without repeat this
repeat you take the from the negative
population to increase the the negative
sample so now the the represent the
marginal frequency is rare and again
with the same scenario where we're doing
the more and repeated k fault so in the
context of Reza I'm showing only to a
one at five percent one at one percent
less than one percent it wasn't really
good to go so I've tested all the way
down here and then with earlier and
without however when the primary
transfer comes in to make that inference
on narrowing that space we see that the
baseline performed better as opposed to
be extended and there are a few reasons
for that mostly because potentially the
extended version is over smoothing so
it's changing the the the curve and so
the area behind it and where the
estimation line falls that's the where
I've kind of found the root of it for
now but but yeah in general so their
idea would be if you're looking for rare
failure subset they without you can do
with parameter transfer with the
baseline version should get you their
highest achieved potential F score but
again it really depends on the data
itself I mean this data had it had some
noise and had some as I showed earlier
there was some overlap in the labels so
but it's real
applied work so we don't expect
hundred-percent so as a summary what I
showed was that the RTF framework
developed which contains the baseline
and extended versions performs better or
equal to the sell down version so I
don't report it down f1 scores the
extended version performed better than
the baseline version relative to the f1
scores and when you're going across data
sets in generalizability and in terms of
rare subsets down to 1% the baseline
with parameter transfer performs the
best out of the other settings that's
and I'm and in terms of doing this with
other types of data in my defense this
is the dissertation I have proved on a
large dataset first atomic layers that
shown that there works there as well as
well as on obviously a single insignia
so in terms of potential future work as
I said the binary classification we can
go to better to multi class saw
population artificial identification
potentially through networks or tree
based methods that this transfer
learning can be applied to to find an
actual and apply to use this to find
course of health and disease and find or
prophylactic protection use this
framework to be able to find kinetics of
gene expression or temporality between
phenotypes pseudo order through the
temporal ordering of the cells depending
on again flux or cycle and putting them
in different lineages or finding these
regulatory networks or these Sailor
morosely systems that exist in us to be
able to classify them as separately
passed subpopulations of cells and built
to study them and with that I want to
thank Mariana who's sitting in the back
over there my partner before all these
years has this supported my emotional
needs and
and you know the PC working you know a
rollercoaster sometimes and of course
with the help of Kenya who's been mostly
an emotional support dog and also want
to acknowledge my mentorship of dr.
McQueen Ian dr. Lewiston and dr. Gould
as well as my committee which includes
dr. McCrae Nia and affluence and as well
as dr. Mooney Chris dr. Zhang dr. Linda
and the external reviewer who's not here
dr. ad and also like to thank David
Lewin send doctors doing send the other
one I just that's how I define it as
well as dr. líderes especially I want to
thank the D my staff and other members
in the denied student cohort and
although not just my cohort or all of
them throughout it was really nice to
know that you guys on here I've really
been enforced by all of you and with
that I take questions thank you very
much
[Applause]
yes pinching jeans so it looks like you
were doing a lot of repeated possible
validations so I'm wondering if you
looked at whether got the top and jeans
and identified at like consensus where
you had to find the same jeans over and
over again and so that they match with
your vendor 47 yeah or was it kind of
like a random ratbag and they never
really allowed I the bag that I started
with is the 405 cell cycle jeans that
they came with but if I can go back to
the little nice first this was not very
like very much but I think still makes
sense I teased a little bit so it
doesn't make the point that so how they
relate to biology and stuff that like
the biology of cell division that's
another little out of the scope but
that's another level to investigate this
to further say actually they make
biological meaning this says
yes sir between the three different
categories of phases it seems like the G
to M phase and the g1 phase phases of
cell subsets were always identified more
easily through the algorithm mech with
the higher f1 score so is there a
generalizable characteristic of a data
set that will work better with your
algorithm versus the egg phase that was
almost always the lowest very in siloam
now that polish they actually say that
specifically that that was the harder
also the hardest one to classify so that
is a similar finding I think that S
phase in general is a complicated state
that the cells are in that there's a lot
of transcription going on and that makes
it a little bit more difficult to narrow
them and there's a lot of overlap like
between the other cell cycle phases but
g1 phase and the g2 and M phase combine
had even further networks with the best
signature and classifying but may be
specifically designed for the S phase
cells but I generally what this is used
for in a pipeline of RNA seek pipeline
for example is to remove cell cycle as a
confounding factor so when you want to
look at other biology who cares about
the cell cycle but it's important in
this case because I'm actually using it
to classify them does that answer the
question
there were more unique mystery
yeah I would say more examples of myself
as well I just launched Dana said I
would might have been able to me to say
oh there's two classes of them maybe and
that but with the number that is there I
can't do that so the gene expression
would serve on classification of
signatures just as well and that's
obviously a slightly different paradigm
than what you're doing with the transfer
learning and I'm just curious your
thoughts on what the right assessment
might be saying similarly rate for
transfer writing are there certain
checks that we should be doing
especially to be cautious about what is
actual because if you know in your last
slide you're using all these different
applications it can be used for one of
those are actually linked to the idea
that the classification itself is
meaningful but and the paper that I'm
referring to would actually argue that
it's just the correlation structure
there's nothing specific and a lot of
these signatures about the actual
numbers of the signatures it's really
about kind of a correlation structure
that is important for the outcome or the
phenotype of interest so do you have any
thoughts on that for future action to
take about computational things you
maybe do a search for transforming I
think that other omics data have to be
integrated like partially thinking about
genes that actually make meaning back I
said biological meaning but like
integrated through other omics like
network from like either gene ontology
or from like phenomics itself that you
can bring in some of those potential
network based omics that integrate into
this to be able to classify or create
these gene sets that are more
biologically meaningful is that is that
what you're trying to say that just not
just a correlation but it's actually
biology
bringing other omics data types that
would help because because I think that
whatever what I'm trying to get at is
given what you've learned which is a lot
about transfer learning in the end
especially some of the concerns around
some of these different methods in terms
of the emphasis that people put on the
actual members of the classifier mm-hmm
but the predictors I guess I was just
wondering if so in your mind it would be
the other data types that would actually
help you I mean I don't think as far as
I can
I've tested I don't find that transfer
learning is unique in this way that
would find gene sets for in fact the way
I found the most through a supervised
method which then I'm using as it
transfer but yeah I think that non
specifically transfer learning but to
improve the meaning of these gene sets I
think that other omics should come in if
if that's okay all right thank you very
much everyone
[Applause]
and we asked the public to leave me in
their battle alone
[Music]